Vegas if you wanna watch sports Vegas  has everything oh that's a good one okay  if she's saving Vegas can I say but  another City is that how it's working  yeah okay I'm a st. Paris so we can have  Vegas oh yeah we had this fool able  coucher yeah it's touchdown over the  Atlantic which prize all of it one city  to destroy  most days I would say the city I would  save would be Los Angeles because I look  too different I live most of my time  Victor  shouldn't we be nervous um yeah that's a  good interesting question always asked  us that question it was one city that we  could save it's a small boat that we're  on I think that's the theme of the movie  and every bit of home is precious every  part is precious and every person is  precious we're a family of man and every  last bug certainly human being but I  think every species every member of the  living family is precious we can't we  can't lose they like to get the  landmarks  you